Corona cop Alex Earl Sydney Sweeney
Leonardo DiCaprio it doesn't matter I
think I think I could win any of them
over
hey it's Tommy smokes and I'm here to
answer the internet
good yeah would you rather [__] the
hottest celebrity girl who has a dick or
Vin Diesel with a [__] can I [__] the
hot summer girl in the butt
yeah well she would [__] me oh sure you
can get both of you huh so if I could
[__] the hot celebrity girl and just
like forget that she has a dick like if
I could just be like oh you get that
thing at it like put that to the side
and then just like grab on her boobies
and kiss her and yeah maybe [__] her in
the ass yeah I would do that that would
the penis would be a it'd be a bit of an
inconvenience that I'd have to work
around but I would figure out a way I'd
get that nut off
if there were stats available for every
aspect of your life what one stat would
you like to see we just actually did
this on the bracket I forget what won
but I think that number of times people
complimented me behind my back if I
could get to see the compliments like
imagine all the genuine compliments
someone gave about you that you didn't
get to know that or I mean how many
poops I've taken probably one or two a
day can I pull up the list of things I
submitted for this bracket episode
absolutely cut this because it can't
nobody could say I was prepared for this
all right this one I have wondered I
would like to know how many people have
crossed my line of sight like just how
many how many people have I seen like
like if you go to a baseball game you
see 50 000 or 40 000 people how many
people in the street like I don't know
what that number is just have crossed my
line of sight I think it'll be cool to
know
like 40 million you saying that just
made me realize I think I think I
finally have mine how many celebrities I
saw that I didn't recognize yeah but who
cares
that's interesting to be like wait dude
I was in the same room as [__] Obama
when was that that would be
disappointing I didn't even do anything
about it I didn't get to take him up on
how bad Obamacare is
if you could be part of the crew from
any TV show or movie what crew would it
be maybe succession like they're just
rich people who all hate you whatever
well they like they'd like me I could
win over Logan Roy I could win over
succession and or what's something
that's like a bunch of hot girls I can
hang out with Charlie's Angels is that
hot girls I like I only like TV shows
where I could pretend that I'm the main
character so it needs to be like a
straight white male around 26 years old
in New York city so maybe
no no no no no no those are the only
ones I could watch is where I could
pretend that I'm the main character so
maybe I don't know Seinfeld but their
lives are not that good I'll go
succession I'd like to you know a little
move in a chicken the politics
a lot of money I could be cousin Greg
yeah yeah okay what's the worst thing
you've got thrown out of a bar for do I
look like a guy's been thrown out of a
bar before I'm smokes I got kicked out
of the Sistine Chapel once does that
count yeah it's not a bar but I was
taking pictures you're not allowed to
take pictures of the ceiling in the
Sistine Chapel so I was pretending to be
on the phone and I was just like taking
pictures of this I don't know what I was
gonna do with a picture of the Sistine
Chapel ceiling but yeah they're like no
no photo and I got kicked out uh but at
a bar there was one time like my for
Halloween my roommate dressed up as me
like the year after the Vape God
interview we like had a vape God hat and
they wouldn't allow him in the bar with
a hat it's like it's [__] Halloween
everybody in there has hats on like if
someone's Tiger Woods like a baseball
wire like no it's a hat you have to you
have to get out of here and he got
thrown out I was like that's [__] so
you got to go too and like all right yep
that's fair yeah I mean he got thrown at
the bar and I got like
a company alongside with him if you got
ten thousand dollars a day for every day
you didn't masturbate how many days
could you last I I would go for for a
while I'd go for 10 000 a day that's see
thirty three hundred thousand
I I would go like four months become a
millionaire off of it I think
1.2 million and I could [__] stuff
during this right and wet dreams I have
a lot of wet dreams oh yeah I've never
had a boyfriend oh you're missing out
you are missing out
I don't believe what dreams next time I
wake up with a lot of [__] in my pants
I'll send you a picture you're in a
dream and it feels like you're really
having sex it's like a hot girl hot dude
hot girl for me but like a good girl hot
dude or if you're gay or if you're you
know feeling I don't know explore
explorative and then you just come it's
like oh I just had sex
yeah you don't even have to worry about
kicking her out would you rather your
girlfriend get a notification every time
you watch porn with the description or
notification of where you are at all
times
um am I cheating on her
hey guys what's up to you I mean if I'm
cheating on her then definitely not the
notification one but I don't I I don't
cheat I wouldn't cheat uh so I'll go
with that notification of porn and I'll
and she'll be like you never watch porn
but yeah I'm getting 10 000 a day but
when I'm not mastered
also I watch pretty pretty standard porn
I just find the first hot girl doing
missionary with a guy what is the
hottest celebrity you'd have a chance
with if they got to know I mean there's
like literally if any if I if you get me
an hour with any celebrity it's game
over you give me one-on-one we go for a
couple drinks I'm able to Showcase my
charm oh forget it Corona cop Alex Earl
Sydney Sweeney Leonardo DiCaprio it
doesn't matter I think I think I could
win any of them over that's why I don't
like pick up girls at bars because
nobody can hear all my little jokes
that's basically what everyone here says
it's just like how we all deal with the
fact that like we don't have it you
could see a sex tape with any two movie
characters who would it be I mean I want
to see Jason Bateman [__]
Jason Bateman an identity thief
and Jessica Alba from Fantastic Four
would you rather date a girl who
constantly sneezes on you or who
constantly farts during sex definitely
constantly fart stories I don't want to
go [__] sneezing on me it's
disgusting I mean the farting on sex
it's like that's
not ideal but I could tell myself to go
it's just the that's the noise of my
dick inside of her is it gonna smell is
it smelly farts
well not all farts smell that's
important part of it I mean a girl
constantly sneezing on me I'd be getting
sneezed on more than
I'm having sex with her it appears uh so
yeah I'll go with the constantly
sneezing or no I'll go I'll go with
farter fart on me can you use a gift
card on a first date no definitely not I
think that a gift card is my least
favorite gift anybody ever gives a
person like don't tell me where to spend
my money I don't want a gift card don't
give me a 50 [__] Target gift card
like give me fifty dollars and I will
spend it how I see fit I also on a first
date like are you gonna have a gift card
to a bar for drinks in the city you'll
look I I think using cash on a first
date is kind of a cool move but a gift
card is the the worst possible thing
that that you think cash in first is a
cool move yeah that's interesting yeah
let's go guys yeah all right no I think
that you're like a felon or I don't
think that I don't think they'd have
that I I don't think I could ever be
convicted of a murder I don't think
anyone would believe it I think if I
murdered like nine people and all the
DNA evidence where they're like this guy
there's no way there's no way he did it
I would say more people who murdered 90
people look like you than of someone
else but my personality too
consider all that I do there's no way I
could ever buy a gun like I should
that's my gun control law is anybody who
looks like me should not be able to buy
a gun because I'm either gonna kill
myself or a bunch of other people I'm
not going hunting
I'm into [__] murder people
if you're selling me this gun just know
what you're doing
thank you for watching answer the
internet please subscribe to the channel
comment below on other celebrities you'd
like to see and make sure you hit the
Bell to get notifications when new
episodes come out